me acabo de dar cuenta que en el vídeo
anterior cometió un error casi al final
pero es un error bastante severo porque
copié el número equivocado y esto llevó
a que todas las cantidades estuvieran
erróneas nosotros encontramos que el
componente vertical de la velocidad
final era menos 26.03 metros por segundo
sin embargo al momento de copiarlo aquí
lo escribí como 29 en lugar de 26 no sé
que estaba pensando pero esto es 26.03
así que la magnitud de este vector es
26.03 y aquí el vector es menos 26.03
aquí estoy indicando la dirección que es
hacia abajo así que para calcular la
magnitud del vector final esto tiene que
ser 26.03 al cuadrado y si lo calculamos
de hecho ya lo hice en la calculadora
aquí está nos queda vamos a cambiar lo
que tengo aquí que me volví a equivocar
26.03 al cuadrado mas 5.21 161 no sé que
tengo hoy pero bueno encontramos la
respuesta y es 26.54 o 26.55 así que
este valor de aquí realmente es 26.55
metros por segundo
esta es la magnitud de nuestra velocidad
final la magnitud de nuestra velocidad
final total
y del ángulo podemos decir que la
tangente de este ángulo con el valor
correcto la tangente de teta es igual al
opuesto entre el adyacente el opuesto es
26.03 entre el adyacente que 5.21 y si
sacamos la tangente inversa en ambos
lados de esta ecuación nos queda que el
ángulo teta es igual a la tangente
inversa de 26.03 entre 5.21 y esto nos
da la tangente inversa de 26.03 entre
5.21 lo que nos da 78 puntos 68
aproximadamente 78.7 grados este ángulo
de aquí es igual a 78 puntos 7 grados y
está por debajo de la horizontal así
pues nuestro vector velocidad final
tiene una magnitud de 26 puntos 55
metros por segundo con un ángulo de 78.7
grados por debajo de la horizontal o
menos 78 puntos 7 grados por encima de
la horizontal
espero no haberlos confundido mucho con
este error al final del vídeo anterior